welcome to this video playing grandma's
turkey star okay so we've got them we've
got the rule base exchange mmm yeah but
when player plays some weird line here
that I looked at years ago check
involving a pawn sacrifice that they
just play then and still what happens I
really don't remember how exactly it
went takes night eggs and no castles but
food it's kind of sketchy my memory
okay I'm Shannon's capsule and I think
rupee it maybe is that right OPH I don't
really remember I can take a couple of
times but that doesn't really help
eight ticks on f6 Knight f6 f5 okay that
doesn't look very dangerous really maybe
I can actually get in Bishop f3 and
takes on e5 which should be kind of okay
okay he actually takes her maybe he can
move the night away but well let's see I
mean II fibers and that I don't believe
him that that move I missed I really
didn't think about it
[Music]
okay so every I've got night age five
and under some circumstances but there's
no way to put the bishop anywhere okay
it's not really threatening this if I go
Bishop d6 what is he doing
Knight g4 is not great I can do that
right at least I should get something
back here
so now I can take f40 fo I think up the
chat get the power back just took me a
long time okay he's threatening f3
so probably let's activate the rook
yeah I'm suddenly clean in good shape
but how good is it
I mean he doesn't his position is
uncoordinated this is why I shouldn't be
fine I can take or rook e8 hmm it's not
quite clear to me what's better I taking
us actually sadly good ideas Bishop f5
now
hmm yeah I'll get an excellent game out
of this just a matter of can you win it
or not so we'll see
so anything better than taking the pawn
probably not so now maybe g6 and bring
the king of
[Music]
yeah my extra point is it's on the
queenside okay then you will bring his
King up here at age five I can still
take so going to go up
[Music]
John it's it's to chat about difficult
to win this whatever should treat you
probably doesn't really matter
check so he's actually encouraging me to
go up over here check check check
Roxy for mate didn't expect that but
it's probably not really a big deal
[Music]
time warning check it's really not much
I can do I can offer a third game yeah I
mean two against one
hmm not much to do if I if I be here
around here I have to do more with this
of course but
yeah I wonder how many how much how
realistic blacks chances to win oh I
should try to avoid the complete
elimination or the Kings side but not
quite sure how I mean I can do something
well I went here here something I can of
course always go all that back yeah and
and keep this this maybe this is the way
to do it
chatting here the likelihood of the draw
is already super fine there this is the
drawer simply I cannot do much it was a
bit surprised that he went for this but
yeah why not I mean he can just trade
stuff and 3 against 2 which is dead yeah
it wasn't interesting opening um jab now
I think this is something that I looked
at at one point rupee eight if he takes
I mean he he did take yeah no I'm sure
threatening to get this back and
something like e 5 is really no good I
was thinking of this but computer
actually wants to play this with a
pretty good game now it doesn't really
help and this after Bishop d6 is better
than me can it just just doesn't seem to
to lose outright Chadwicks takes that's
that's
yeah here no we're getting somewhere the
engine now I mean I I just sort of
automatically played Bishop f5 and
taking that cashing in but this is a
very interesting move given by the
computer
yeah that's pretty strong actually yeah
he cannot take off and cause of Jack and
the rook loss
Luke a3 and now C form and here just
keep the pressure on with this kind of
idea that's very awkward and he also I
have this dominating Bishop against
somewhat loose night yeah this is the
key mm-hmm interesting that it was much
much stronger than what I played well
maybe next time thanks for watching